all right so a lot of the Bernie support
is obviously mixed with the black lives
matter support and you know one of the
things I've been saying about the black
lives matter movement is their
intentions are good and somehow what's
happened to the movement seems to have
been hijacked or derailed by I think
what you would call far leftists do you
agree with that or do you think the
movement was always that way where do
you see it now where do you see it going
well I mean back in 2013 2014 myself and
Infowars were on the forefront of
exposing police brutality I mean
probably 25% of my content every day was
about police brutality now that that
whole narrative has been hijacked by
black lives matter it makes you less
enthusiastic to actually talk about
police brutality the effect that they've
had and the polls show this is massive
support for police departments across
the United States because the tactics
that they engage in are so divisive and
turn ordinary Americans off to such a
degree that now a lot of people simply
would immediately support the police
even in a flagrant case of police
brutality so you know yeah you have to
go back to the founding of black lives
matter obviously a lot of well-meaning
people jumped on board in the first six
months or so but the inspiration behind
black lives matter and this is the woman
that the three female founders of that
embryonic group said was their
inspiration was a woman named Assata
Shakur now she's on the FBI's most
wanted terrorist list because she killed
a cop in New Jersey back in the 70s and
then fled to Cuba this is a woman who's
you know black lives matter activists
they invoke her name at nearly every
rally
she's a domestic terrorist who left the
Black Panther Party because it wasn't
violent enough she joined the Black
Liberation Army you know this was
another domestic terror group that was
involved in bombings and assassinations
killing police officers so when you have
that kind of guru that inspiration
behind
movement obviously it's gonna tend
towards violence you had black lives
matter protesters in New York walking
down the street chanting what do we want
dead cops when do we want them now
that's only gonna turn people away from
your movement so it's not an inclusive
movement it's being a divisive movement
since almost the beginning since just
after the first Ferguson protest and
it's only got worse as it's been
hijacked by all these opportunists and
operatives yeah so for you as you said
you guys were ahead on this stuff and I
remember seeing a lot of videos that you
guys were doing where you were talking
about police brutality before it had
really bubbled up into the mainstream
news so it must be extremely depressing
for you as someone that like is in this
and you talk about this you understand
that there was something good here and
as you just laid out that it has been
derailed how do you how do you get it
back to that is it too late is the is
the wave already gone to get it back to
what was right dealing with legit issues
about police brutality
well when the entire movement you know
BLM was founded on this Michael Brown
case the whole hands up don't shoot me
and the media peddled that for what six
months or more the autopsy of course it
turned out that was complete BS
he never had his hands up so they baits
all their grievances on these completely
fraudulent cases and then you have a
case like Eric garner which was a you
know a legitimate act of police
brutality which you know we supported
the victim in that case but they they
tend to base all their grievances on
these ridiculous cases that are
obviously justified use of force by the
police so it's it's difficult to see how
we're going to get back to a rational
conversation about it when these people
are you know invoking the inspiration
the Guru or the domestic terrorist
they're chanting for dead cops you know
you had people plan to bomb the Ferguson
Police Station you had the cops that
were killed in New York as part of a
black lives matter revenge attack by
Ishmael Brinsley so when it attracts
those kind of extremists I mean at this
point
I call it a domestic hate group if this
was a bunch of why Oregon militia
members who were you know chanting for
black cops to be killed or black people
to be killed who some of them were
actually planning to do that and whose
ideological inspiration was Timothy
McVeigh for example the media wouldn't
get behind that when we've seen elements
of the media get behind black lives
matter we've seen you know time magus
Time magazine in defense of rioting so
they built this whole grievance industry
it was supported by some elements of the
leftist media and now you've got Hillary
Clinton meeting with black lives meet
leaders back a few months ago saying
she's prepared to change laws for them I
think this is very you know divisive
destructive movement and it's D
legitimized genuine opposition to police
brutality which was an issue and
continues to be an issue but now people
are so turned off towards that as I said
the polls show that people don't like
black lives matter and now more likely
to support police yeah you know a
perfect example of that would be sort of
what you alluded to which is what
happened in Oregon here what two months
ago when you know the crime and Bundy
people they took over basically a vacant
you know lot house office and everyone I
saw all my progressive friends were
screaming about what terrorists they are
domestic terrorists I'm not defending
them they walked into a federal building
even if nobody was there in the door was
unlocked with weapons and I think maybe
one person did die somehow related to it
or something you could correct me if I'm
wrong on that but there was such outrage
over that where there was virtually no
violence not defending everything that
they did versus the lack of outrage when
there's actual violence so everything
comes down to race at the end of the day
with the progresses right well yeah that
was there was a young guy holed up there
in the in the Wildlife Center right at
the end of that situation who was
threatening to kill himself and it was
being broadcast live on the internet it
was trot it was a tragic situation but
on Twitter you had all the regressive
celebrating it calling him a racist and
saying you should shoot himself in the
head you had a lavoy finicum who was in
the vehicle you know with a cub
these are the protesters females
traveling through this FBI roadblock he
gets out of the car he gets gunned down
god knows two dozen times or whatever
that was a shady situation but again as
he said a complete lack of outrage they
filled the car with bullets it's a it's
a surprise that these are the women who
were unarmed and we're not showing any
resistance didn't get slaughtered
themselves but on the left there was no
outrage whatsoever because they weren't
black I think we should treat everybody
who's a victim of police brutality the
same regardless of race but because they
don't do that it turns you know white
middle class America away from their
movement and it prevents us from
becoming truly United in addressing
police brutality yeah I mean that's it
right there there unintended
consequences of what they do actually
drive drive people the other way what
would you say - I have progressive
friends most of them well most I won't
talk to me anymore but I had progressive
friends that when we when we discuss
this stuff they would say well a certain
amount of violence if you really want
social change a certain amount of
violence is necessary do you buy that at
all or do you think that's just an
excuse because look you're not gonna get
headlines if if there isn't a certain
amount of violence right if you do that
peaceful both protests the media doesn't
show up well I believe in non-violent
civil disobedience I mean if you look at
everyone throughout history who's
actually changed society if you look at
you know Gandhi or Martin Luther King
who know the progressives are trying to
disavow because he wasn't inclusive of
transgender people then they don't need
to resort to violence because their
cause is powerful enough where people
become a threat to the establishment
when they unite black people when they
unite white people when they unite
people from different political
persuasions they don't become a threat
when they resort to violence because
they can be easily demonized and dealt
with by the state so no I don't I think
that's a terrible idea I think it's
gonna be unsuccessful yeah and it's also
directly linked into why these
regressives and now we can get into the
regressives somehow we did 45 minutes we
barely said the word progressive why
they label every
you me everybody else as bigots and
racists and everything else because
there they can't control people without
splitting us all down into the little
racial markers or you know this one's
oppressed more than you know as somebody
keeps saying the the oppression Olympics
basically so let's talk about the the
regressive was your wake up to them at
the exact same time as you sort of woke
up to the social justice warrior stuff
or did it come a little bit after that
when you really saw that there was this
group of people that was was protecting
and pushing this ideology well they
probably correlated you know with the
rise of Isis with these terrorist
attacks in Europe with the migrant
crisis and the fact that we're importing
people from bad cultures and I mean
that's the heart of regressive ISM you
know it's self-proclaimed liberals who
defend and tolerate non liberal
ideologies and I think because at their
heart their cultural relativist right
they believe that all cultures are equal
well I don't believe that I think there
are bad cultures and good cultures I
made a video a few days ago some
cultures are better than others but the
heart of progressivism is this idea of
utopianism so there can't be such a
thing as a bad culture accepting the
fact that there are bad cultures
demolishes utopianism so that's why
progressive so-called progressives can't
entertain the fact that there are bad
cultures even for a second even though
they've blatantly are I mean you know
when US troops blew the whistle on how
Afghan police officers were bringing
young boys onto the army base and raping
them and they were told to shut up about
it because that was quote part of their
culture I think that's a bad culture you
know when UNICEF has to do PR campaigns
to educate 600 million Indians half of
their population not to defecate in the
street because it's you know causing
deadly infections and child malnutrition
that's a bad culture we need to call out
bad cultures because I don't think
importing them into the way
is compatible with Western ideals of you
know liberal tolerance but the the
regressives can't entertain that for a
second because their cultural relativist
they can't entertain the notion that
some cultures are better than others
which is why in germany for example
these migrants that came in and you know
started defecating in hot tubs start
masturbating in swimming pools started
raping children in swimming pools one of
the swimming pools in germany responded
by banning male migrant yeah how did the
regressive left respond to that they
complained they said it was racist they
intimidated they forced the swimming
pool into lifting the ban because again
they can't entertain the notion that
some cultures are worse than others and
that's the heart of you know regressives
it's this utopian idea that everybody's
the same and everybody's equal even
though this is bad behavior that we
shouldn't be accepting and embracing in
the West yeah and there's really no end
to it right that's why this snake will
eventually eat its tail because you know
if you look what happened in Germany you
know right on New Year's with with all
the rapes and all the sexual attacks on
women suddenly all the regressives were
defending basically the perpetrators
they kept saying not all Muslims all
this stuff nobody was saying all Muslims
people were saying the specific people
here who did this they have these set of
values they're the ones that did it
that's what a rational person would say
we didn't say this is condemning every
single person that believes in this and
yet they go to defend that so they throw
women under the bus so it's like they
have their pecking order and in this
case women came below the migrants
because the migrants are mostly Muslim
yes the whole oppression Olympics idea
and you know when it came out in Cologne
it later emerged that most of the
perpetrators were not newly arrived
refugees they were migrants who had been
there for several years and they're
aggressive celebrated this right yeah
how dare you demonize the refugees this
was done by migrants okay so migrants
who were supposedly assimilated they've
been there for years and yet this is the
kind of behavior they're engaging in and
that's something to celebrate I mean
that's again that shines light on the
heart regressive ISM and as he said you
know after every single terror attack we
hear the same thing again and again
don't blame Islam not all Muslims are
terrorists nobody ever suggested that
that's never been part of the debate
they try and frame the debate so it
becomes that because they can't win when
you actually drill down you know into
the statistics and show that this isn't
a tiny minority of people this is why
bang on about again and again you know I
make videos saying Islam's not a
religion of peace get death threats as a
result of it I guess to prove that it is
a religion of peace but I mean you can
look at the statistics this is not a
tiny minority of people this is a
problem within Islam this is why we need
to support the voices of reform within
Islam soap you had a poll for example
the percentage of Muslims who think that
suicide bombings are justified under
some circumstances they asked Muslims in
European countries so in France 31% of
adil Muslims over the age of 30 think
that suicide bombings are sometimes
justify if you look at young people aged
18 to 29 that goes up to 42% think that
suicide bombings are sometimes justify
and it's similar in you know Spain 22%
of adults think the same Germany 10% and
22% of those aged 18 to 29 think that
suicide bombings are justified you've
also got huge numbers of Muslims
throughout Europe in France for example
27 percent of Muslims aged 18 to 24
support Isis so again this is not a tiny
fringe minority of people 21 percent of
Syrians support Isis these are the
people who were bringing it so it's that
this lie that the Islamophobia industry
upholds that it's just you
tiny fringe minority it isn't and the
the facts the stats prove that yeah what
do you think of the word Islamophobia I
assume you're not a fan of the word
itself right because it's an imaginary
word you can't fear a set of ideas you
can fear actions that people might do
and Islam itself says a lot of bad
things about infidels like the two of us
right so it's not an irrational fear to
fear this set of ideas it's just this is
just a made-up word right that doesn't
discount that there might be bigotry
towards Muslim people but the word
itself is a slippery slope right well
it's becoming too changeable with racist
doesn't it yeah I mean at this point the
Islamophobia industry is is bolstered
and exaggerated to such an extent I mean
there are Islamophobic attacks and
they're horrible and we shouldn't decry
them but it's those are anti Muslim
attacks right not not Islamophobic
attacks right they're not afraid of the
idea of something they're they're afraid
of the people right yeah those are
basically racist attacks but if you look
at actual hate crimes you know that
they're far outweighed by anti-semitic
attacks for example in in most Western
countries so I think that's exaggerated
we saw that again in molenbeek
just the other day where the media
reported that a right-wing protester had
run over a Muslim woman later turned out
that it was a Muslim team from molenbeek
who ran over the Muslim woman so there
are these these fake Islamophobic
attacks it was another one on Wall
Street where a Muslim woman says she was
slashed across the face she turned out
was completely made of so again
you know at this point why not own it
why not say yes I'm afraid of an
ideology that supports Sharia law that
supports stoning women to death
executing homosexuals killing people who
leave the faith of Islam yes I'm very
afraid of importing those kind of ideas
into the West and when for example 50
percent of Muslims of American Muslims
support the right to live under Sharia
law in the United States that's a
problem and I'm going to call attention
to that figure because it's it's way too
I and to call attention to that figure
is not to be Islamophobic it's to be
rightly concerned about these intolerant
beliefs being imported into the West as
they now are in such great numbers so
for people like us that want to have
honest discussions about this without
bigotry and without hyperbole and I know
it's very hard to do and we don't win
any points for doing this really but for
people like us and I know it's a growing
movement should we start thinking of
Islam more as a political ideology than
a religion because people no matter how
many times we separate ideas verse
people religion first people people
can't seem to do it they just there's a
certain amount of people they cannot
detangle these two things but I'm
starting to think that if we start
describing these actions as political
actions killing gays not good you know
in a pressing women not good if these
were political a political party was
pushing these ideas the left would be
completely against it so is that sort of
how we have to not to give up our
tactics publicly right now but is that
how we have to start focusing on this
argument I think it is exactly I mean
you know sam harris Maajid Nawaz they've
outlined the fact that this is not just
jihadist the problem isn't just jihadist
yes you can point to that and say that's
a tiny minority but the main problem is
Islamist you know I agreed with Obama
when he said terrorism is not an
existential threat I mean we're not
gonna all be killed by terrorists it's
not going to be such a massive you know
onset of terrorist attacks that it
proves an existential threat but when
you import these ideas that are
incompatible with Western society and
that's a direct to our quality of life
our culture and the entire underpinnings
of Western society as a free liberal
tolerant society so we have to emphasize
that distinction that there are not just
jihadis there are Islamists
I mean look at Salah Abdeslam they're in
molenbeek in Brussels he was protected
yeah four months after the Paris
massacre by his friends and neighbors
okay they're not jihadis they haven't
gone out and slaughtered anybody but
they were protecting
Hadas because there is Lamas and this is
this is the problem when we get huge
numbers of people moving into Western
societies they create these ghettos they
create centers of power and then Isis
comes out in its manifesto and says
we're going to encourage the creation of
these ghettos in the West to radicalize
these populations to support our cause
then that's a problem I mean you can get
an ak-47 on the streets of molenbeek
within a few hours for 400 euros that
doesn't just arise out jihadis that's
this whole Islamist support network that
protects salah abdeslam for example so
that's a distinction we need to
emphasize to leftists and regressives
again it's not a tiny minority we have
to include Islamists as part of the
problem and if you include them as part
of the problem the figures show that
it's a de-stressing proportion of people
who support advocate and promote these
intolerant beliefs yeah and i know no
matter how many times we repeat the
difference between jihadists and
Islamists and the average nominal Muslim
somehow that just can't get through to a
certain amount of people but before I
let you go I want to dive into the
immigration thing a little deeper
because you've done a lot on it and when
I've watched some of your videos you
know we really in the mainstream media
in the United States we barely talked
about it I would guess that if you watch
CNN 24 hours today that you wouldn't see
one story on it literally not one minute
on it and then I watch you our videos
and some other people and I'll watch
them stuff on the BBC or something like
that and I get a sense that it's a big
problem and I get tons of messages
mainly I'm getting a ton of stuff from
Sweden especially talking about this
would you say out of a ten where where
is this thing at right now I mean is
this really as bad as the videos that
you put out it makes it sound like
there's a massive crisis right now or is
some of it overblown is it different for
every country I'm still struggling to
get a hold on it well it's different for
every country that tends to be a tipping
point when a country goes above for
example six to seven percent Muslim
population that's when you get the no-go
areas which the media still
is a conspiracy theory I got chased out
of one in molenbeek I can attest to the
fact that it's not so that's the kind of
tipping point I mean to illustrate this
you can look at the prison populations
in these different European countries so
for example Belgium which of course just
suffered the Brussels attack the Muslim
population is around 6% but the prison
population of Belgium comprises 45%
Muslims the 45% of the prisoners in
Belgium are Muslims despite the fact
they only make up 6% of the population
you look at France six to ten percent
Muslim population but the prison
population is 70 percent Muslims same in
Spain Muslim population 3.7 percent
prison population is 70 percent Muslim
so obviously something is broken here
and we were getting the create words
seem the creation or more of these
ghettos they don't assimilate for our
political leaders want to bring them in
for their own agenda which is the goal
of importing huge numbers of people from
the third world to vote for bigger
government if you look at polls
conducted amongst Muslims they typically
support expanded welfare state and they
vote once they become citizens for
bigger government so they've placed
Europe security they placed our entire
social contagion under grave danger in
favour of advancing this political
agenda yeah do you think it was that in
the case of like angle of Merkel do you
think it was that calculated like my
sense is that there was some level of
guilt because of the Holocaust and
Germany still is trying to deal with
that that they partly were trying to do
something good here they brought this I
think it's 1.2 or 1.3 million people and
and that it is just crushing the system
and creating all this resentment and a
country that has has a tough history
with xenophobia it's only gonna get
worse and it's hard to believe that she
knowingly did this even if it was just
to get votes which it's not working
right because didn't some of the right
parties just win elections know that it
was the reaction to that I mean
the past couple of years you've had a
basically a conservative backlash sweep
in Europe that your elections in 2014
proved that so it was a backlash to that
now of course
500,000 migrants who have come into
Germany haven't registered with
authorities so that's gonna become a
massive problem but yeah a lot of it was
virtue signaling on steroids right so
you had you know the German Green Party
politician Stephanie von Berg she got up
in front of the German parliament and
said quote our city will change
radically I hold it in 2030 years there
will no longer be a German majority in
our city and that's a good thing
yeah so she said that simply as a way of
pissing off the right wing in Germany
they would bring in these migrants to
displace the German population so part
of it is virtue signaling on steroids
part of it is that guilt about the Nazis
which of course we have to remember only
a minority of the German population
actually supported the Nazi Party in the
1930s so I would argue that why would
you punish you know German citizens
taxpayers now we've got Germans being
kicked out of social housing to be
replaced by migrants over 1.2 million
migrants brought in already over the
past year and again politicians
celebrating the demographic suicide of
their country and it clearly isn't
working because every single day we have
these cases of people being raped now
the primary victims of rape are Muslim
women and girls in these moment my Grand
camps but now you see these reports of
you know Afghan migrants raping boys in
swimming pools and quite frankly I'm
sick of seeing it every single day yeah
this is a bad culture these people
aren't being assimilated if you import
huge numbers of people at breakneck
speed with no clear plan on how to
assimilate them there's gonna be bedlam
there's gonna be chaos and that's now
why top military chiefs in Sweden in
Switzerland in Norway warning that this
could lead to civil unrest and out
war basically if it if it continues this
way yeah
man I wanted to end with you on a
positive note can we figure out how to
do that where's Europe gonna be in ten
years any hope well as I said I mean a
lot of these parties are being voted out
of power and that's been happening for
the past couple of years so there is a
kind of backlash against it you know I'm
all for limited skilled immigration I
don't I think that's healthy for a
society but the way it's going you know
three hundred thousand immigrants every
year coming into the United Kingdom
we've only got a population of 60
million and that's after that that's the
number after the other ones have left so
it's going to become overwhelming it's
gonna cause more problems more riots but
from a positive perspective you know my
videos your videos about this are
reaching a huge audience because the
media continually lies about it they
don't point out that 72% of the people
coming in and man these are generally
not families four-fifths of them at one
point weren't even Syrians but the fact
that I can do a video about this and it
gets over a million views proves that
people are thirsty for the truth and we
are shaping the narrative and eventually
the hope is that that will change
government policy by sheer force of
pressure
all right well listen that's exactly why
I try to have these conversations and
that's why I like the work you do and
you know what here's what we'll do - for
anyone that's watching this that thinks
that anything that Paul said was
conspiratorial or unfactual tag me on
Twitter with them and we'll talk some of
this stuff out will you make that
commitment we'll talk some of this stuff
out with a couple of the people not
everybody I'll do it
you'll do it alright so it's at prison
planet on Twitter and he's doing all
these videos on YouTube and I thank you
guys for watching and Paul you stayed up
late for me so I appreciate it thanks a
lot man
you